Shure: 好嘞好嘞
Shure: Alright, alright
Shure: 辛苦你
Shure: Thanks for your hard work
Shure: 然后打车票子啥的你就留好
Shure: And keep the taxi receipts and stuff
Shure: 到时候跟那个小畅报
Shure: And report them to Xiaochang later
Shure: 啾啾啾啾啾啾啾啾啾啾啾啾啾
Shure: Chirp, chirp, chirp, chirp
Alice:待着能能睡吗
Alice: Can I sleep here?
Tasha: 这是什么
Tasha: What is this?
Shure: 就是那个打孔器
Shure: It's a hole puncher
Shure: 打耳洞的
Shure: For ear piercings
Tasha: 真的假的
Tasha: Really?
Shure: 真的呀
Shure: Yeah, really
Shure: 你看那不还有碘伏呢吗
Shure: Look, there's iodine right there
Shure: 然后涂完碘伏然后把耳耳朵夹在里面
Shure: You apply the iodine, then clip the ear in
Shure: 然后一摁
Shure: And press it
Tasha: 真的假的
Tasha: Really?
Shure: 对啊就穿过去了
Shure: Yeah, it goes right through
Shure: 没想到吧
Shure: Unexpected, right?
Jake:哼哼确实没想到哼
Jake: Hmm, didn't expect that, huh.
Jake:确实很难想这个
Jake: It's really hard to think about this.
Tasha: 我真的想打个耳洞
Tasha: I really want to get my ears pierced.
Shure: 试试
Shure: Try it.
Shure: 是不是差点就信了
Shure: Almost believed it, didn't you?
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha.
Shure: 对不起
Shure: Sorry.
Shure: 怎么样怎么样这个
Shure: How about this?
Shure: 骗人的本领
Shure: The art of deception.
Shure: 撒谎不眨眼
Shure: Lying without batting an eye.
Tasha: 甩了他他不专心
Tasha: Dump him, he's not focused.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha.
Shure: 不
Shure: No.
Shure: （歌词）的我的心
Shure: (Singing) My heart.
Alice:这有用吗这还
Alice: Is this useful?
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Oh man.
Shure: 猜猜这这一坨是谁压的
Shure: Guess who pressed this down?
其他人：你都这么问了
Others: You already asked that.
Shure: 是的没错就是我
Shure: Yes, it was me.
Shure: 我以为他整
Shure: I thought he fixed it.
Alice:这坨东西还有用吗
Alice: Is this thing still useful?
Shure: 有
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 很有用
Shure: Very useful.
Alice:搁哪
Alice: Where to put it?
Shure: 这几个是谢彬竹的那个我靠
Shure: These few are Xie Binzhu's, oh my.
Shure: 还有一个应该
Shure: There should be one more.
Alice:那要不你给他收起来
Alice: How about you keep it for him?
Shure: 啊对
Shure: Ah, right.
Shure: 这四个是谢彬竹的
Shure: These four are Xie Binzhu's.
Shure: 这个是杨老板
Shure: This one is Jake's.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Shure: 杨老板这个是什么的
Shure: Jake, what is this for?
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:12345有5个
Jake: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, there are 5.
Jake:这边不用翻
Jake: No need to flip this side.
Jake:但是没地放
Jake: But there's no place to put it.
Jake:放后面随便找地放
Jake: Just find a spot at the back.
Jake:这一层就5个
Jake: There are just 5 on this level.
Jake:这种目一词
Jake: Just a word.
Alice:这是不是搬下去啊
Alice: Should we move this down?
Alice:这个木凳子
Alice: This wooden stool.
Alice:般一个
Alice: Just one.
Shure: that
Shure: That.
Shure: 这也说不用搬下去了
Shure: There's no need to move it down.
Shure: 就放这了
Shure: Just leave it here.
Shure: 哎呀音箱拔下
Shure: Oh no, the speaker is unplugged.
Shure: 哎音箱已经拔了
Shure: Oh, it's already unplugged.
Shure: 音响我想直接寄回家了
Shure: I think I’ll just send the speaker home.
Shure: 反正我在学校应该也用不到了吧
Shure: Anyway, I probably won't need it at school.
其他人：你可以寄回我家啊
Others: You can send it to my place.
其他人：不对我有音响
Others: No wait, I have a speaker.
Shure: 这是一个监听音箱应该也没有什么用
Shure: This is a monitor speaker; it's not really useful.
Alice:西瓜什么时候买的
Alice: When did you buy the watermelon?
Alice:刚刚
Alice: Just now.
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh.
Shure: 因为没买到刮刮乐所以就给
Shure: Because I couldn't get scratch-offs, so I got everyone a watermelon instead.
Shure: 大家买个瓜
Shure: I got everyone a watermelon instead.
Alice:哈哈哈好谢谢
Alice: Hahaha, thanks.
Shure: 但是我买的这个盒子我已经找不到了
Shure: But I can't find the box I bought for it.
Shure: 怎么能给他安全的寄回去
Shure: How can I send it back safely?
Shure: 我总不能背着他背回去吧
Shure: I can't just carry it back, can I?
其他人：嗯你要是我不会的
Others: Hmm, if you were me, I wouldn't.
Shure: 我不会的
Shure: I wouldn't either.
其他人：我说你要是从学校去的话
Others: I mean, if you’re going from school.
Jake:呵呵呵儿子
Jake: Haha, son.
其他人：我那倒是有盒子还有泡沫纸
Others: I do have a box and foam paper at my place.
Shure: 行从你那薅薅吧
Shure: Okay, I'll grab some from you then.
Shure: 哎这应该也不缺什么泡沫纸
Shure: Oh, it probably doesn't need much foam paper.
Shure: 盒子什么的东西
Shure: Just the box and stuff.
Shure: 到时候再想一下
Shure: I'll think about it later.
Shure: 有道理
Shure: Makes sense.
Shure: 你好聪明耶
Shure: You're so smart.
Shure: 你又做那个青蛙脸干什么
Shure: Why are you making that frog face again?
Shure: 帮我帮我
Shure: Help me, help me.
Shure: 低了一下这个尾巴
Shure: Lower this tail a bit.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 好
Shure: Good.
Shure: 那我们就下去吧
Shure: Let's head down then.
Shure: 被他拽折了
Shure: He broke it by pulling it.
其他人：走吧你
Others: Let's go!
Alice:这个也是垃圾吧
Alice: This is trash too, right?
Shure: 我上个厕所
Shure: I need to use the bathroom.
Shure: 好像是吧
Shure: Seems like it.
Jake:眼镜呢
Jake: Where are my glasses?
Shure: 哎哎
Shure: Hey hey.
Jake:哎眼镜呢
Jake: Hey, where are my glasses?
Shure: 眼镜在这
Shure: The glasses are here.
Shure: 我先我先去上个厕所
Shure: I need to go to the bathroom first.
Jake:哦那请
Jake: Oh, please.
Jake:请上请上
Jake: Go ahead, please.
Jake:没关系哈哈哈
Jake: It's okay, hahaha.
Shure: 这需要这样的数据
Shure: This needs this kind of data.
Jake:导演也没那么需要
Jake: The director doesn't need it that badly.
Jake:但是我们也不太排斥
Jake: But we don't really mind either.
Jake:哈哈虽然不需要
Jake: Haha, even though we don't need it.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha.
Shure: yesand是吧哈哈
Shure: Yesand, right? Haha.
Jake:不需要但是也行啊
Jake: We don't need it, but it's fine.
Shure: 尹夕阳同款
Shure: Same as Yin Xiyang's.
Shure: 呵呵尹夕阳同款
Shure: Haha, same as Yin Xiyang's.
其他人：真不是同款
Others: It's really not the same.
其他人：我那天看了
Others: I saw it that day.
其他人：他那天穿
Others: He wore it that day.
其他人：我看真不是同款
Others: I saw, it's really not the same.
Jake:你也可以在房间里面坐着
Jake: You can also sit in the room.
Jake:但是不能动
Jake: But you can't move.
Jake:你作为房间里面的一个
Jake: You are like a part of the room.
Katrina: 为什么
Katrina: Why?
Katrina: 啊啊
Katrina: Ah, ah.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Katrina: 没事你先扫吧我再
Katrina: It's okay, you clean first, then I'll...
Jake:对对对狗狗我放门口
Jake: Yeah, yeah, I'll put the dog at the door.
Shure: 您好
Shure: Hello.
Shure: 你为何在这里摸鱼
Shure: Why are you slacking off here?
Shure: 你在干嘛
Shure: What are you doing?
Katrina: 我在镇定自己
Katrina: I'm trying to calm myself down.
Katrina: 我有点想吐
Katrina: I feel like throwing up.
Shure: 太不好了整个人
Shure: That's really bad.
Shure: 宝你在搜什么宝
Shure: Darling, what are you searching for?
其他人：把一个吹出去就是那种
Shure: 白色垃圾
其他人：对是的
Shure: 好的加油
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: 我们今天要把这个房子拆成什么样
Shure: 就是完全恢复原样是吗
Jake:啥啥啥啥啥
Shure: 我说我们今天要把这房子拆成什么样
Jake:拆成原样
Jake:你你拿的时候记得啥样不
Shure: 那那那个什么go Pro的时候也拆
Jake:那当然得拆
Shure: 今天都拆是吗
Jake:今晚都拆
Shure: OK
Shure: 暖风吹呀吹
Shure: 你把我这衣服拿过来了
Jake:对我这电脑也要全拆了
Jake: Yeah, I need to completely take apart my computer too.
Lucia: 哇哦
Lucia: Wow
Jake:哦呦
Jake: Oh no
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry
Jake:我这电脑还得全
Jake: I still have to completely
Jake:也得全拆了
Jake: take it apart too.
Jake:回头你们还能打把麻将
Jake: Later you guys can still play some mahjong.
Shure: 哎呦哎呦
Shure: Oh man, oh man.
Jake:开心了不
Jake: Are you happy now?
Shure: 快快拆
Shure: Hurry up and take it apart.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Shure: 我觉得杨老板那屋拆的刻不容缓
Shure: I think Jake's room needs to be dismantled urgently.
Shure: 因为他一直压着那麻将机
Shure: Because he's been blocking the mahjong table.
Lucia: 这就是你一直没能打上的原因是吧
Lucia: So that's why you haven't been able to play, right?
Shure: 对啊
Shure: Yeah
Jake:对等了一周了
Jake: Yeah, I've been waiting for a week.
Jake:可算能打上了
Jake: Finally, we can play.
Jake:呵垂涎三尺
Jake: I'm drooling in anticipation.
Lucia: 哎呀这就剩一个了
Lucia: Oh, there's only one left.
Lucia: 我给大家收拾收拾
Lucia: Let me tidy up for everyone.
Lucia: 尾声呵呵呵
Lucia: The finale, haha.
Jake:对是是一个麻将的尾声
Jake: Yeah, it's the end of a Mahjong game.
Jake:然后谁谁赢先谁先走
Jake: So, whoever wins first goes first.
Shure: 小黑你好
Shure: Hi Nicous.
其他人：么东西
Others: What are you talking about?
Jake:呵呵谁赢谁先走
Jake: Haha, whoever wins goes first.
Lucia: 什么什么
Lucia: What? What?
Lucia: 谁谁谁谁
Lucia: Who, who, who?
Jake:谁先胡谁先胡谁先走
Jake: Whoever wins first, goes first.
Jake:不胡不准走
Jake: If you don't win, you can't leave.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 不扶不准走
Lucia: If you don't help, you can't leave.
Lucia: 妈呀
Lucia: Oh my.
Lucia: 那我
Lucia: Then I...
Shure: 锁好门我要呼把大的哈哈哈
Shure: Lock the door, I'm going to win big, hahaha.
Lucia: 那我这种不会打的岂不是走不了了
Lucia: Then I, who can't play, can't leave?
其他人：没事
Others: It's okay.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Jake:没一个
Jake: Not one.
其他人：人都走了就只剩你了
Others: Everyone will leave, only you will be left.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
其他人：你就可以走
Others: Then you can leave.
Lucia: 就没有人管我了是吗
Lucia: So no one will care about me, right?
Lucia: 不行那这房间至少要剩下4个人
Lucia: No, at least 4 people have to stay in this room.
Lucia: 因为当只剩3个人时候就没法打了
Lucia: Because when there are only 3 people left, we can't play anymore.
Shure: 哎我找一个袋子
Shure: Hey, I'm looking for a bag.
Shure: 还剩不剩
Shure: Is there any left?
Shure: 什么盒马的袋子了咱们这
Shure: Any Hema bags left here?
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Lucia: 那是我的裤子吗
Lucia: Is that my pants?
Lucia: 这么长时间还没洗完吗
Lucia: Still not washed after so long?
Jake:那女的半个小时挺长
Jake: Women take a long time, half an hour is long.
Shure: 我要装那些东西
Shure: I want to pack those things.
其他人：箱子装不开吗
Others: Can't the box fit them?
其他人：我昨天背那个包也能装东西吧
Others: I carried that bag yesterday, it can hold stuff too, right?
Shure: 这点的话
Shure: At this point...
Shure: 主要是这点
Shure: Mainly this point...
其他人：直接放箱子里嘛
Others: Just put it directly in the box.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 哦谢谢你
Lucia: Oh, thank you.
Shure: 你说的对
Shure: You're right.
Shure: 来吧帮我收拾收拾
Shure: Come on, help me clean up.
其他人：我
Others: I...
Shure: 是的少爷
Shure: Yes, young master.
Shure: 少爷没干过这活
Shure: The young master has never done this before.
Shure: 快帮帮忙
Shure: Quickly, give a hand.
其他人：什么东西
Others: What is that?
其他人：好红啊他
Others: It's so red.
Shure: 他粉的
Shure: It's pink.
Shure: 要试试吗
Shure: Do you want to try it?
其他人：妈呀红的要命
Others: Oh my god, it's so red.
Shure: 粉的哈哈哈
Shure: It's pink, hahaha.
其他人：你这已经粉粉成红色了
Others: It's so pink it's turned red.
Shure: 你是你是
Shure: You are, you are.
其他人：感觉像什么单位
Others: Feels like some unit.
其他人：团建的那种妈呀哈哈
Others: Like those team-building events, oh my god, hahaha.
Jake:嚯这是要跳舞这是
Jake: Whoa, are we going to dance?
其他人：哈哇我也觉得他这件衣服
Others: Haha, I also think his clothes...
Jake:上广场这是
Jake: Going to the square?
其他人：你看正常人哪会买这种衣服啊少爷
Others: Look, would a normal person buy these clothes, young master?
Shure: 我妈买的
Shure: My mom bought it.
Shure: 你婆婆买的
Shure: Your granny bought it.
其他人：少什么奶奶
Others: Young what granny?
Shure: 哈哈哈少什么奶奶
Shure: Hahaha, young what granny?
Shure: 哈哈哈那叫老夫人
Shure: Hahaha, that's called the madam.
其他人：我再过40年可能喜欢这个颜色吧
Others: Maybe in 40 years I might like this color.
其他人：真像什么公司团建
Others: Really looks like some company team building.
Shure: 这就普普通通
Shure: This is just ordinary.
其他人：这个好看
Others: This one looks nice.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 我那口咖啡是不是还没喝上
Shure: Did I not get to drink my coffee yet?
其他人：是的
Others: Yes.
Shure: 没电
Shure: No power.
其他人：百分之八
Others: Eight percent.
Shure: 他还有电居然
Shure: It still has power, actually.
Shure: 这这冲着他
Shure: This, this is charging it.
Shure: 冲完了他冲完了
Shure: Done charging, it's done.
Shure: 插了吧
Shure: Plug it in.
Shure: 不主要我的塞尔达是数字版
Shure: But mainly, my Zelda is the digital version.
Shure: 所以马寄回
Shure: So sending it back...
Shure: 来也没有用其实
Shure: It’s actually useless.
Shure: 这个戴夫我还没玩呢
Shure: I haven't played this Dave yet.
Shure: 因为这样的话记录不同
Shure: Because the records would be different.
其他人：你塞尔达保存了吗
Others: Did you save your Zelda game?
其他人：正在运行
Others: It's running.
Shure: 应该是没保存吧
Shure: I don't think it was saved.
Shure: 我看保存好了
Shure: I see it was saved.
Shure: 星之卡比很好吧
Shure: Kirby Star Allies is pretty good, right?
其他人：我刚刚就想开这个
Others: I was just thinking of starting that.
其他人：然后意识到
Others: Then I realized
其他人：你的塞尔达不知道有没有存
Others: I didn't know if your Zelda was saved.
其他人：所以问你一句
Others: So I asked you.
Shure: 你看你就很好
Shure: You see, you're thoughtful.
Shure: 会问我存没存
Shure: You ask if I saved.
Shure: 我妹直接给我关了
Shure: My sister just shut it off directly.
Shure: 气死我了
Shure: It pissed me off.
Shure: 我还不是
Shure: And it wasn't even
Shure: 上次不是塞尔达
Shure: Zelda last time.
Shure: 是我玩动森
Shure: It was when I was playing Animal Crossing.
Shure: 我在这修了一下午的那那什么家呀
Shure: I spent the whole afternoon fixing up that house,
Shure: 墙啊桥
Shure: Walls, bridges,
Shure: 结果我妹没给我保存直接给我退了
Shure: And my sister didn't save and just quit the game.
Jake:好啊动森
Jake: Wow, Animal Crossing.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Yeah.
Jake:疫情那会躺床上就玩是吧
Jake: During the pandemic, you just played it in bed, right?
Jake:疫情刚开始那会是
Jake: At the beginning of the pandemic.
Shure: 怎么了
Shure: What's up?
其他人：咋了你有几条腿
Others: What's up, how many legs do you have?
其他人：谢斌竹给你带这么多裤子
Others: Xie Binzhu brought you so many pants.
Shure: 谁知道呢
Shure: Who knows?
Shure: 有谢斌竹给我收拾
Shure: Xie Binzhu packed for me.
Shure: 他就给我带了一件白t四件外套
Shure: He brought me one white T-shirt and four jackets.
Shure: 哈哈哈真是正常人类能能带过来的
Shure: Hahaha, like a normal person would pack like that.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 呃中间其实不用写应该
Shure: Actually, we shouldn't need to write anything in the middle.
其他人：放吧那个一会要拆开了
Others: Put it down, it's going to be taken apart soon.
其他人：那个那个那个那个那个这个
Others: This, this, this, this, this one,
其他人：不能不能不能不能拉上拉链了
Others: Can't, can't, can't, can't zip it up.
Shure: 怎么了要要把这个拆开是吗
Shure: What's up, do we need to take this apart?
其他人：啊不是
Others: Uh, no.
其他人：我是说这个拉链不能拉了
Others: I mean, this zipper won't close.
其他人：因为他会比箱子要大一点高一点啊
Others: Because it's a bit taller and bigger than the suitcase.
Shure: 这放哪
Shure: Where should we put this?
Shure: 怎么放
Shure: How should we place it?
Shure: 他这也不能冲下
Shure: It shouldn't face down.
Shure: 这个这有个啾啾哎对
Shure: There's a little bow here, yeah.
Alice:啊给我粘胶带
Alice: Ah, give me the tape.
其他人：哎对
Others: Yeah, right.
Alice:开始扫了
Alice: Start sweeping.
Alice:干嘛呢你当虫呢
Alice: What are you doing, pretending to be a bug?
Alice:能给我粘牢固点吗
Alice: Can you stick it more securely?
Alice:这胶随便使
Alice: Use the tape freely.
Shure: 最好他冲下或者冲上
Shure: It's best if it faces down or up.
Shure: 不行就把这线先卸了
Shure: If not, we can remove this line first.
其他人：不不不我觉得这样OK
Others: No, no, I think it's fine like this.
其他人：     箱子够大吗
Others: Is the suitcase big enough?
Shure: 箱子我不知道
Shure: I don't know about the suitcase.
Alice:谢谢你小姐姐
Alice: Thank you, miss.
Shure: 这厚外套应该穿不上了
Shure: This thick coat might not fit.
Shure: 晚上应该不会冷了吧
Shure: It shouldn't be cold tonight, right?
Shure: 可以这样可以
Shure: This way is fine.
Shure: 底下先垫个这个
Shure: Put this underneath first.
其他人：太厚了太厚了
Others: It's too thick, too thick.
其他人：你的外套太厚了
Others: Your coat is too thick.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 那你说它太厚
Shure: You said it's too thick.
Shure: 但那个不是就是没有什么缓冲的吗
Shure: But doesn't that mean there's no cushioning?
Shure: 哦侧边的话我拉着应该也没问题
Shure: Oh, if it's on the side, it should be fine if I pull it.
Shure: 没事问题都不大
Shure: It's fine, it's not a big problem.
Shure: 反正400块钱而已
Shure: Anyway, it's just 400 bucks.
其他人：你还有什么要放吗
Others: Do you have anything else to put?
Shure: 没了吧啊
Shure: No, that's about it.
Jake:你的店
Jake: Your store.
Shure: OK
Shure: Okay.
Jake:别忘了星之卡比
Jake: Don't forget about Kirby.
Jake:一会在我来之前要弄完
Jake: Finish it up before I come back.
其他人：那是个啥呀
Others: What's that?
Shure: 什么好
Shure: What is it?
Jake:一会我要扫这边所以
Jake: I'll sweep this area later.
其他人：那是个啥呀
Others: What's that?
Shure: 什么
Shure: What?
Shure: 谢斌竹的某个笔盖吧
Shure: Probably a pen cap from Xie Bin Zhu.
Jake:我上面可能扫他个20分钟吧
Jake: I might spend like 20 minutes on it.
Jake:然后20分钟之后
Jake: And after 20 minutes...
Jake:你们就要悄悄的跑到二楼去躲着对
Jake: You guys need to quietly run to the second floor and hide, okay?
其他人：我袋子里面是什么哦
Others: What's inside my bag?
Shure: 这是我的内衣
Shure: That's my underwear.
Shure: 放那你
Shure: Put it there.
其他人：你别往那边塞
Others: Don't stuff it over there.
其他人：还有什么
Others: What else is there?
Shure: 没了
Shure: Nothing else.
Shure: 剩下基本上就一袋咖啡豆剃胡刀
Shure: The rest is basically just a bag
Shure: 还有自己看看吧
其他人：那这个直接背着就行了
Shure: 对
其他人：背着这个背着哎我包呢
其他人：外套外套外套
其他人：你穿不了那么多吗
其他人：你有几个头啊
Others: How many heads do you have?
Shure: 谁知道
Shure: Who knows?
Shure: 这是个小防晒服吧
Shure: Is this a little sun protection clothing?
其他人：小鹦鹉
Others: Little parrot.
Shure: 鹦什么舞鹦鹉
Shure: Parrot what? Parrot dance?
Shure: 我怎么就鹦鹉了
Shure: How did I become a parrot?
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahaha!
Shure: 录一下
Shure: Record this.
Shure: 记录一下
Shure: Note this down.
其他人：记录什么
Others: Note what?
Shure: 妈妈你看
Shure: Mom, look.
Shure: 我有新爸了
Shure: I have a new dad now.
其他人：我想想
Others: Let me think.
其他人：这个能放你包里
Others: Can this fit in your bag?
其他人：这些能放你包里啊
Others: Can these fit in your bag?
其他人：话筒也是你带的吗
Others: Did you bring the microphone too?
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
其他人：这些能放你那个背的那个包对
Others: Can all these fit in that bag you're carrying?
Shure: 背的就没什么了其实
Shure: There's actually not much in the bag.
Shure: 哦我还有睡衣
Shure: Oh, I also have pajamas.
Shure: 睡衣回去得洗了
Shure: Gotta wash these pajamas when I get back.
Shure: 天呐好幸福
Shure: Oh my gosh, so happy
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure: 还有一个水库啊
Shure: There's another reservoir
其他人：等一下我试一下
Others: Wait a minute, let me try
其他人：那个那个
Others: That one, that one
其他人：那个外套要是不穿的话就别再放了
Others: If you don't wear that jacket, don't put it back
Shure: 星之卡比在响
Shure: Kirby's making noise
Shure: 谢谢你妈妈
Shure: Thank you, Mom
Shure: 哈哈AI蒙了
Shure: Haha, AI is confused
Shure: 这两个人到底是什么关系
Shure: What's the relationship between these two people?
Shure: 天
Shure: Oh my
Shure: 你简直就是
Shure: You're just
Shure: 整理master
Shure: an organizing master
Shure: 哎那边那个袋子没没进去
Shure: Hey, that bag over there isn't in
Shure: 我也不知道他是什么带子
Shure: I don't even know what bag that is
Shure: 妈呀
Shure: Oh my
Shure: 太厉害了
Shure: So amazing
Shure: 南昌没有你我怎么回南昌
Shure: How can I go back to Nanchang without you?
Shure: 好的
Shure: Okay
其他人：继续游戏
Others: Continue the game
Shure: 继续就好
Shure: Just keep going
Shure: 嗯稍微教你一下
Shure: Hmm, let me teach you a bit
其他人：所以这是出生点是吗
Others: So this is the spawn point, right?
其他人：还是你上次结束的地方
Others: Or where you ended last time
Shure: 不是这是大地图
Shure: No, this is the big map
Shure: 这才是a是跳
Shure: This is it, A is jump
Shure: 然后这就是所有的关卡
Shure: And these are all the levels
Shure: 我可以从这开始
Shure: I can start from here
其他人：嗯
Others: Mm-hmm
Shure: 这应该就是教学关卡
Shure: This should be the tutorial level
Shure: 然后长按b
Shure: Then hold B
其他人：长按什么
Others: Hold what?
Shure: 长按b就
Shure: Hold B and
Shure: 是c然后再按下b就是吐出去
Shure: it's C, then press B to spit it out
Shure: 对像这个也可以吸
Shure: Yeah, you can inhale this too
Shure: 然后像这种就可以吞下他
Shure: And you can swallow this kind
Shure: 然后就会变成他的
Shure: Then you'll become like him
Shure: 获得他的能力
Shure: Gain his ability
其他人：啊我知道
Others: Ah, I know
其他人：这个我知道
Others: I know this
Shure: 然后
Shure: And then...
Shure: 这时候NB就变了吗
Shure: Did NB change at this point?
Shure: 还可以吃回来然后按B
Shure: You can still eat it back and then press B.
其他人：这是什么东西
Others: What is this thing?
Shure: 这个是就我把这个能力给升级了
Shure: This is, I just upgraded this ability.
Shure: 然后这叫塞满嘴
Shure: And this is called "stuffing your mouth."
Shure: 按住b就变成这个样子
Shure: Hold down B and it becomes like this.
其他人：可爱
Others: Cute.
其他人：你为什么不领那个金币
Others: Why didn't you collect that coin?
Shure: 可以试试
Shure: You can try it.
Shure: 那就是胶囊
Shure: That's a capsule.
Shure: 胶囊扭蛋
Shure: Capsule gacha.
其他人：咦
Others: Huh?
Shure: 你打的呀按B
Shure: You hit it, press B.
其他人：猪呢
Others: Where's the pig?
Shure: 死了
Shure: It's dead.
Shure: 你就不不塞了
Shure: Aren't you going to stuff it?
Shure: 你就从这上去
Shure: Just go up from here.
Shure: 长摁a就会啊
Shure: Hold down A, and it'll...
Shure: 他好像可以连续摁a
Shure: It seems like you can press A continuously.
Shure: 你试一下
Shure: Give it a try.
Shure: 你连续按A
Shure: Press A continuously.
Shure: 你就多摁一下
Shure: Press it one more time.
Shure: 对对
Shure: Yes, yes.
Shure: 它可以这样
Shure: It can do that.
Shure: 然后再摁下b
Shure: Then press B again.
Shure: 它就下去了
Shure: It'll go down.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure: 你又回来了
Shure: You're back again.
其他人：我需要探索什么地图
Others: What map do I need to explore?
Shure: 你需要通关
Shure: You need to clear the level.
Shure: 跟着标牌走哈哈哈
Shure: Follow the signs, hahaha.
Shure: 嗯下去
Shure: Hmm, go down.
Shure: 然后找到这个星星
Shure: Then find this star.
Shure: 就是相当于过关啊
Shure: It's like clearing the level.
Shure: 不是也不是
Shure: No, not exactly.
Shure: 只是传送到下一个地方
Shure: It just teleports to the next place.
其他人：这又是个啥呀
Others: What is this again?
Shure: 你不用管这个
Shure: You don't need to worry about this.
Shure: 你打不掉他
Shure: You can't beat it.
Shure: 我可以啊这身法
Shure: I can do this, with these moves.